well al Qaeda in Iraq was effectively
beaten three or four years ago and
what's happened is that this is is group
which is an extremist jihadist group has
been able to group itself in Syria arm
itself finance itself growing numbers
and now it's come over the border from
Syria into Iraq and with the the chaos
and the carnage we see and you know this
is the problem i'm afraid that as a
result of what has happened in these
last few years we've had a situation
where syria is in the state of
disintegration and now that has come
back over the border into iraq now of
course there are many reasons within
Iraq itself why this has happened as
well not least the sectarian nature of
the government there the inability to to
build their own Armed Forces capability
in the right way but I'm afraid we've
now got this problem right across the
middle east it's a fundamental problem
we'll have to deal with it I mean but
you went back three or four years I was
trying to go back 11 years to the just
before the war started just before the
invasion and and that feeling that
belief within some senior members from
the Bush administration indeed not
particularly held in Britain that Saddam
Hussein was in alliance with al Qaeda
that was not the case not in any
significant form but that is now a
tragic reality yeah but we got to see
what's actually happened in this in this
last period of time and you can go back
and debate what happened 11 years ago
but the reason why we we have this
problem right now is is twofold first of
all this what has happened in Syria's I
say where this is is group has grown up
they actually planned this assault into
Iraq from Syria but the other point
which is really important to realize is
this because some people will say well
if we hadn't removed saddam in 2003 we
wouldn't have the problem today in Iraq
and the reason I think that is
profoundly mistaken is this since 2011
there have been these Arab revolutions
sweeping across the whole of the region
Tunisia Libya Yemen Egypt Bahrain Syria
next door to Iraq in Syria
and we can see what would have happened
if we'd left Saddam there in 2003 in
Syria we have left basher Assad in Syria
the result is that there have now in the
last three years in Syria been virtually
as many people killed as in the whole of
Iraq you now have nine million people
displaced from Syria you have chaos and
instability being now pushed across the
region a country like Jordan for example
the days got almost a quarter of its
population now Syrian refugees so my
point is you can carry on debating about
whether it was right or wrong what we
did in 2003 but whatever had been done
you were always going to have a problem
of deep instability in the region and in
Iraq so let's be careful the question is
now what do we do about it so let's be
clear mr. Blair you feel no personal
responsibility whatsoever for the
current sorry state of iraq look of
course there's the I've got personal
responsibility for the decisions that
were taken in 2003 that's not my point
my point is that whatever had been done
in 2003 you were always going to have a
situation where Iraq was in a very
difficult position because the whole of
the region is in a difficult position
today and as I say if we taken the
opposite decision in 2003 Iraq would be
in precisely the situation that Syria is
in today well that's so okay it's not a
question well I mean but that's not the
cases it whatever was done in 2003 leave
aside the invasion what happened
immediately after that when Paul Bremer
the US Representative was put into
effectively run Iraq and then he
disbanded the Baathist party he said if
you're a bath party member you can't be
a member of the civil service you can't
be a teacher and disbanded the Iraqi
army surely that was a mistake in rock
might have become a more stable society
whatever happened in the Arab Spring
right just go back to 2003 and look at
the debate there was at the time because
people now say well it was very obvious
she shouldn't have disbanded the army
and so on there was a fierce debate at
the time precisely because the army at
the time was in the control of the Sunni
minority in Iraq the majority of the
country is here and we're saying both
the Americans and the British at the
time
you cannot leave this army in place you
cannot leave the bath party in its
position of power so again you can go
back 11 years and debate what happened
then but I simply put this point you
Dermot given what has happened in all
the countries I've just mentioned across
the region is it seriously incredibly
being said that the Arab revolutions
would not have come to Iraq they would
have and so the idea if you'd left
Saddam there you would have a peaceful
situation in Iraq whatever happened in
2003 you were always going to have a
situation once these Arab revolutions
started sweeping the region where you're
going to have the problems that you've
now got and by the way we have three
examples now of Western policy in
respect of calling for regime change we
have Iraq where we called for a gene
change we change the regime we put in
troops that proved very difficult as we
know we have Libya where we call for
regime change we use their part to get
rid of Gaddafi we didn't put in ground
troops Libya is now exporting chaos and
instability and terrorism across the
region and down into Africa now in
sub-saharan Africa and thirdly we've got
the example of Syria where two years ago
we called for a sad to go we haven't
taken action to make him go and now we
have the situation in Syria which is in
the worst state of all three countries
as dealing with zoo yeah I mean so
dealing with the reality of that
situation in Syria the reality of it now
with a sad still partially in place you
say in this essay you've written today
that Assad cannot win an outright
victory can he win a partial one and
should we deal with him on that basis
right well this is a very good question
I'm afraid and this is the challenge
that we now have because what is
necessary is to understand that a sad
Romanian power is bad but also that the
opposition is now fragmented between a
reasonable and moderate and modern
minded group of people and these
jihadists these extremists so what we're
going to have to do is to come to an
arrangement somehow in Syria where there
is a process of transition a new
constitution put in place but it's going
to be very very hard to do that and
you'll have to involve everyone in that
process including those people who are
now supporting a sad so I'm afraid it is
a very difficult
situation in Syria but be under no doubt
at all because this is what is it so
important about our own attitude to this
people after Iraq said right when it
comes to Syria we're not having anything
to do with it we're going to stay out of
it and it's someone else's problem if
you talk to British security people
today or the French or the Germans their
single biggest anxiety about our own
security in our own country today our
returning jihadist fighters from Syria
so my point is I understand entirely why
people want to say stay out of it it's
someone else's fight it's got nothing to
do with us but unfortunately the people
were dealing with they are going to pull
us into this whether we like it or not
that does not mean a let me make this
clear I'm not suggesting we put ground
troops in and we do a full-scale
invasion as we did in Iraq or
Afghanistan but I am saying we are going
to have to take an active role in trying
to shape events in Syria ok rock and a
deed across the region well and as you
said they're just clarify for as part of
that is coming to an accommodation with
people who are supporting a sad do you
draw the line at a sad himself staying
you got well I don't think there's any
way a sad staying certainly in the
medium and long term is going to be
acceptable but I'm afraid this is the
blunt and brutal reality if you want an
agreement in Syria today you're going to
have to factor in the the idea that for
the majority people in Syria today they
simply want the violence to end and they
want some attempt to rebuild their
country you're not going to be able to
do that unless there is a fully
inclusive government and so was it wrong
in terms of sad again was it wrong of
the British Parliament in effect last
year to veto any military action against
president of the sad and in particular
his use of chemical weapons did we make
the wrong call in this country well in
my judgment as I said at the time yes
because look for two to three years now
I've been saying to people i am samuel i
we'd look I'm not saying anything I
didn't say at the time I mean obviously
if I be no House of Commons
time I would have been supporting the
freedom for us to take action if we
needed to and you know let's be clear
about what's what's happened in Syria as
I say you literally you know I think
I've now virtually as many people killed
in Syria is in the whole of the heroic
conflict since 2003 and you've got the
situation where you're spilling out
instability right across the region and
it's a country by the way disintegrated
if you look at what's happened to cities
like Aleppo that were proud civilized
cities going with a history stretching
back over centuries there now wrecked so
the point is this unfortunately because
all of these problems in the Middle East
they arise out of this toxic mixture in
my view of bad politics and bad religion
and what's happened is that that these
groups these extremist groups are able
to operate destabilize countries and the
majority of people and by the way this
is the good news about the Middle East
the majority people actually want to
live in peace but they're not being
allowed to buy these extremist groups
and the reason why whether we like it or
not we're going to get involved in this
ultimately is because these extremist
groups also intend to target us do we
need to get involved in some form
militarily again in Iraq when you say
involved you certainly don't need to put
in ground troops no one's calling for
that no one's wanting that I think the
American government and the American
president are now considering all their
options and we should obviously give
what support we can in those
circumstances so I won't specify exactly
how but yes we it is in our interests in
our interests for this jihadist
extremist group to be stopped in its
tracks in exactly the same way that in
my view it's in our interests are
British national interest to make sure
that the situation in Syria is
stabilized and resolved and as I say I
understand entirely why people say it's
got nothing to do with us we don't want
we don't want to hear about it but
unfortunately the people that we're
fighting out there or the people that
are are they
extremists who are causing this
instability in this chaos they are not
simply if I fighting Iraqis or fighting
Syrians they're also prepared to fight
us and they will if they're not stopped
and does what's happening in Iraq throw
doubt in your view on what's happening
in terms of the military withdrawal from
Afghanistan well i think you know as I
said constantly in respect of
Afghanistan it's got to be on the basis
of the job being done so you know there
is anxiety about the withdrawal in
Afghanistan on the other hand as you can
see the Afghan forces are obviously in a
wholly different stage of preparation
and equipment today and the people are
coming out to vote and I think in the
Afghan election I think one of the
things we've got to understand about
this is sometimes we look at the Middle
East or you go wider than that you look
at Afghanistan you look at Pakistan you
look right across the the the the whole
of North Africa and people in our
country say look it's all just a big
mess these people don't want our help
anyway it isn't really true what what's
actually happening is that in these
majority Muslim countries the majority
of people within those countries in fact
they want what we want they want the
rule of law they want stability they
want some chance of risperidone topper
tunity and hope for their young people
but because of the history of this
mixture of religion and politics there
are unfortunately well-armed
well-financed groups who are prepared to
cause instability and chaos and what I
think we've got to understand is whether
it's in Syria Iraq Afghanistan Libya
wherever it is our job in my view
because they also pose a threat to us is
to support those open-minded modern
minded people who want the right type of
changes with within their country and
not to believe either that it's hopeless
or that we can afford to disengage I
just finally Mr Blair on the overall
reason you've written this this long
thoughtful essay on the subject we've
been discussing and just talk within
it's about delivering these messages
with humility is taking part a response
to your old friend Robert
is saying that so while you were in
office you developed a Messiah Complex
that you're a narcissist who went mad
for I can't really comment on on what
what he might write these are difficult
decisions you know I say it with
humility because I had to handle global
affairs post 9-11 and I've never said
that that the people who disagree with
me a stupid or wrong I understand the
arguments both ways I think we would
have a more healthy debate if we
understood that these issues are our
profound and complex that the decisions
are not easy and that we try to
understand as I'm trying to understand
how to move forward given that there are
no easy solutions and you know over
these past seven years since I left
offers I mean I spend a lot of time out
in this region I think about these
issues I study them and I you know wrote
that the long essay if you like because
I want people to understand on a sound
bite but in a more in it in a deeper way
you know what I see in this region what
I see the solution is and why it affects
our own interest so you know I'm not
really interested in trading insults
with anyone over it I just think we're
going to face a big problem in our own
country if we don't understand both the
complexity of the situation and the need
to deal with it Tony Blair many thanks
thank you